penser que les français sont trop
sévères avec trump alexandre de vécu il
ya 69 % des internautes là qui nous
disent oui trump fait cavalier seul je
pense qu'il a un style qui est
incompatible avec la tradition française
très américain qui apparaît extrêmement
vulgaire pour nous il vient de la télé
réalité et c'est ça plus un battage
médiatique où on peut dire 100 % des
médias français sont en titre home de
manière parfois excessif donc oui je
pense que les français sont sont trop
sévères son bilan législatif pour
l'instant cela dit est assez faible mais
il apparaît effectivement comme le
défenseur de la souveraineté aux états
unis et le retour de la politique
finalement je trouve intéressant dans le
phénomène trump quoi qu'on pense dans le
détail deux de ces mesures c'est qu'il
dit bon j'ai décidé ça en conformité
avec avec mon élection et ce sera ça ça
change des gens qui nous explique que
c'est pas possible parce qu'il ya le
droit international qui a le droit
européen qui a ceci cela est finalement
certains disent que c'est
antidémocratique moi je trouve que c'est
assez démocratique que quelqu'un qui a
été élu pour un programme l'appliquent
sans se préoccuper des organisations
internationales du droit international
et c'est donc il ya un combat qui entamé
mon avis qui va être le combat du futur
peut-être pour tous les chefs d'état
entre l'état de droit qui finalement en
train de prendre la place des
souverainetés nationales et le retour
des nations avec une forme de démocratie
plus directe